now one of the last fugitives wanted in
connection with the 1994 random genocide
will appear in court in the next few
hours fulgence kaishima was arrested in
South Africa on Thursday after 20 years
on the Run he's accused of organizing
the killing of nearly 2 000 Tutsis who
were Sheltering in a church let's go to
famida Miller who's live for us in Cape
Town so before we find out what's going
on in court today give us a bit of
context here because it's taken over two
decades to find this man how was he
Tracked Down In The End
well that search is also very
frustrating for the United Nations for
their tribunal given that it said that
South African authorities knew way back
in 2018 at the very least that Fulton's
Kashima was in South Africa in Cape Town
specifically and he was arrested in Paul
on Wednesday as you'd mentioned now
they're tried to get South African
authorities to cooperate
um and having them issue a warrant of
arrest and that was only done much later
but at the time that it was known that
he was in South Africa the South African
government at first said that he had he
was he was in South Africa on a refugee
status and and for that reason they
couldn't cooperate with that request by
the tribunal to have him arrested their
meetings and negotiations continued for
months and the later on said that South
Africa did not have any legal basis on
which to cooperate with the Tribunal but
following months and in fact years of
negotiations and uh pursuing uh fujin's
kayashima he was then arrested and now
that has been accepted by the United
Nations and uh South African authorities
they say they're pleased with coming
this far he's expected to appear in the
quarters behind us as you said there in
the coming hours so what are we
expecting next so he appears in court
and then will he eventually be
extradites it back to Rwanda what's the
process
so while he's facing charges of genocide
and conspiracy to commit genocide as one
examination by the tribunal here in
South Africa he'll face a separate set
of charges which includes that red
notice by Interpol as well as
immigration laws and most likely linked
to him living in South Africa under a
false name that's how he was also found
and of course this mysterious issue
around Refugee status we accept expect
proceedings to begin in the coming hours
where he'll also remain under the
custody of South African authorities
before as the authorities here say he'll
be extradited to Rwanda to face those
genocide charges okay thank you for that
update for Middle Miller there for us
outside the court in Cape Town